I rarely Break characters the animal
like on set because Karen was the only
human and he's so contained because the
vampires get to be over the top great
character of like you know almost like a
farce you know and that's improvised
constantly all the time like our show is
made of 50 scripted and 50 YouTube yeah
yours is 50 improvised that's why this
cast I've never been with the cast like
this where everyone's firing on all
cylinders it's playing like hot potato
and the potatoes never dropped we had us
we had a season one take that ended up
being about 20 seconds in the show but
we shot for maybe 28 minutes of improv
just let the camera roll